this is Startalk this is Startalk
and I'm your host Neil deGrasse Tyson
your personal astrophysicist and I'm I
hail from the American Museum of Natural
History right here in New York City
where I also serve as the director of
the Hayden Planetarium my first
planetarium as a kid when I was 9 years
old and I was never the same since then
I think the universe found me for this
edition of star talk it's the ever
favorite cosmic queries fielding your
questions on a pre solicited topic and
today's topic is the multiverse I know
you've read about it I know you've heard
about it and I know you're itching to
know more and I've got my co-host Chuck
nice Chuck a nail help you're gonna help
me get through this that's right I have
the questions right am I very high
solicited from all over the internet
wherever our fans may be found and maybe
they're inquisitive little minds want to
know all sorts of things and and I need
a backup for this cuz I know a little
bit about the multiverse but I had
claimed no particular expertise in it so
we get on the horn and called what my
old friends and colleagues Paul
Steinhardt Paul hey welcome to Startalk
well thank you professor physics
Princeton University yes and you are a
proponent of one of the multiverses that
people have been talking about well I'm
not sure I put it quite that way but I'm
actually a proponent of alternatives to
the multiverse oh so I'm not a big fan
of the multiverse oh okay the multiverse
destroyed one of my favorite ideas oh oh
the problem for you from me okay so what
was your idea that the multiverse
destroyed well it's an idea that we call
cosmic inflation hmm
so one of the long-standing problems
that we've had in trying to understand
the universe is why the distribution of
matter and energy is so uniform on large
scales and we thought we had well in
other words I look to one side of the
universe
there's statistically a number of
galaxies and stuff and any direction I
look it kind of looks like that that's
right so and you're saying it shouldn't
look like that well according to our
initial idea of the Big Bang the
universe should have emerged from some
random quantum state and been very had a
very uneven distribution of matter and
energy and space itself should have been
curved and warped and all that should
have happened is that you just stretched
that out over time very very slowly
so that if you looked at the universe
today you should see remnants of that
unevenness and war things like an area
where there's tremendous amount of
matter and other areas where there's
hardly anything yeah and and bizarre
curvatures of the space-time continuum
yes like a fire yeah unpredictable in
the way it moves it has certain burn
patterns and so you would look for that
to see where the fire how it progressed
in certain air but it wouldn't be like a
very uniform I hadn't thought of using
fire but yeah I guess if a room would
not burn uniformly because some things
others are more flammable than others
let me tell you something you have no
idea I just bailed you out but I was
just like the way you looked at me I was
like ah [ __ ] the bed again Cho will try
to come wrap our heads around this okay
continue Paul okay so we thought that
the idea for solving this problem was to
have a period of very rapid acceleration
accelerated expansion occurs right after
the bang so that instead of expanding
and that sort of slow modest rate that
would preserve this unevenness instead
you would stretch it at such a space at
such a fast rate that the matter and
radiation would all that existed before
would all be spread out dissipated all
you'd have left is the energy that would
be driving this expansion this super
expansion
and then when that energy decayed into
ordinary matter and radiation that we
see today because it made the matter and
energy or one in the same
MC squared tells us that yeah but it
also includes light and other forms all
forms of energy then you would discover
that the only energy that was left was
very uniform yet very uniformly
distributed so that was the initial idea
that seemed to be a sweet idea for
explaining how you would get physics
this universe we see the universe we see
which is has its peculiar and unexpected
uniformity okay so then we came up with
another added idea to this which is in
this description I just gave you I
didn't include anything about quantum
physics so I said just stretching the
universe would make it uniform but
quantum physics resists uniformity it
produces fluctuations random
fluctuations that that that prevent
perfect uniformity and they would lead
to some regions of space ending
inflation slightly before after the
average so you wouldn't end up with a
perfectly uniform universe you'd end up
a universe with a specific non
uniformity in the distribution of matter
you can predict that you that we thought
we could predict okay that seemed to be
predictive it seemed to be something you
could work out on the back of an
envelope you could work out on the back
of my supercomputer equals you in the
back of your envelope okay but the and
and curiously enough those naive
predictions agree with what we've
observed when we actually look out in
space with the pattern of unevenness
that existed in the early universe it's
uh it's not as uneven as it might have
otherwise been yeah it has the right
amount of unevenness that's consistent
with the hypotheses this not with this
naive calculation so this is what's
wrong okay the problem well there are a
couple of things wrong with this idea
that as we've discovered the first is
that it presumed that after the Big Bang
it would be easy to get this inflation
that just by introducing the right forms
of energy hypothetical energy into the
universe you could automatically start
inflation and so you could begin with a
very random uneven state and start the
influence
inflation to occur when you needed it to
match the universe that we know yes but
you also need to start the inflation it
needs to ignite if you somehow and we
can we phonology to flames yes we
thought it would be easy to ignite but
we discovered actually the opposite is
true
so as an analogy imagine that I was
trying to I told you at a theory for how
to become a billionaire and I am very
interested I thought you I'm right one
might think I'm taking notes okay so I
have a theory how to become a
billionaire and I show you a little part
of my theory which tells you how to
invest some money and sure enough it
demonstrates that it could make some
money by following that procedure and so
you buy my theory and I give you the
book which which explains the theory and
you open up to page 1 it says page 1
let's assume that your parents were
billionaires so basically this is Trump
University right I've become a
billionaire to start with a billion
dollars right well this is essentially
what happened the story of inflation we
thought originally just simply
stretching the universe would be easy an
easy start but we discovered actually we
only under very rare conditions
essentially the conditions you needed
you need to start with Universal which
was already smooth enough and unwarped
enough only then can inflation start so
it's just like saying I need to have a
billion dollars in order to become an
order to make a billion dollars okay so
that was the first big problem and we've
never gotten around that up to the
present time we've known about this for
30 years but we haven't been figured out
despite lots of clever attempts how to
get around that 30 years now I'm waiting
waiting is it because the problems
harder because you all just aren't smart
enough it's because probably it's
actually not a good way of smoothing the
universe out okay I would say it's
probably not a good idea it's probably
not a good book that I that I gave you
for the billionaire right recipe then
the second problem that we found is well
suppose I let you start as a billionaire
okay I'll give you the conditions you
need to start inflation okay but and I
let you choose your inflationary energy
to have whatever properties you want we
thought that you could then calculate as
I said on the back of an envelope what
the predictions would be but there's a
little something that we left out of the
story that we didn't realize when we
thought about these quantum fluctuations
that slightly change the rate at which
inflation ends one place to another
inevitably there's also going to be
regions which are going to have large
quantum fluctuations there are not going
to just delay the end of inflation by a
little bit but by a huge amount and the
longer you delay because it's inflation
is stretching the universe so fast the
bigger those regions become so a typical
region is not the region you thought it
was which just had tiny fluctuations a
typical region in terms of where most of
the universe is is one of these huge
regions which continues to inflate and
then itself it will repeat the process
we patches of it will end inflation but
patches of it will continue so that
alters within it within it and so it'll
keep producing patches and patches and
patches with most of the universe
continuing to inflate and only rare
patches where it ends we don't see these
patches we and mote according to this
idea we would live in one of these
patches but these patches are not all
the same this is where the problem
begins to break down looking around we
don't see such non uniformity in the
universe you only think yeah you see we
see uniformity we don't see any evidence
what's our entire universe is one of
these patches which is that which is the
that's one kind of multiverse but that
is one patch of the multiverse right and
that is and but the problem is that so
just to be clear yeah this is not a
universe in some other dimension right
no no no this is all one universe area
volume whatever in a meta universe and
we think in it's our own it's our thing
right yes we think it's everything right
but but outside of that our patch if you
went far enough out would be more
inflating universe and finally you did
another patch
that patch would have different property
right due to fluctuations lots of
fluctuations would cause different
properties in that little pack that
means you can actually travel within
this universe from one patch to another
and then experience different slightly
different laws of physics too bad and
the reason is because this between these
patches is growing so fast it's continue
to inflate that light or neither you in
a rocket nor light could make up the
difference so we can't overcome the
expanding boundaries between us yes yeah
beat the expansion right you can never
get ahead of that expansion right so
you're never gonna reach that patch
right Wow so it's completely it's there
and it's like no because you don't want
to wander into a place that has slightly
different laws of physics yeah for
example where all the molecules in our
body would decay into radiation that
wouldn't be a good news perhaps I show
up in the wrong outfit okay how would
you ever test this well it's actually
hard to test this idea because one of
the consequences of this idea is over
time you produce patches of ever ever
increasing variety so that every
conceivable possibility that can occur
will occur in some patch so the patch
that has a slightly different law of
physics will have patches that are
slightly different from it yes will have
patches slightly different from it right
Wow so it's a theory where you're
freaking us out here that is freaking
crazy man well I think it is because our
goal was to explain why the universe is
the way it is and we haven't exams are
exploding but yours had exploded long
ago would you just cool with it you know
you know what's what's also like blowing
my mind is that I mean it's so
incredible that you're able to
conceptualize this as all a part of like
you say the meta universe one expansion
where where as our our common perception
of a multiverse is we're making jumps
and leaps to these parallel universes
that are existing on different planes
your
saying no it's this is like whirlpools
in a giant lake yes yeah that's amazing
that a connected space yes yes okay
we're not done with you here no I know
here we go of course we always start our
queries with a patreon patron these
people who paid to get their question
first yes because even fair listen
that's all we know life is not fair
their supporters of the show support the
show and so we support them back ok I
giving them preferential treatment
mutual back scratching you got it Oh
same reason why my parents like me
better than my siblings at least they
pretend to here we go
Christopher Cohen from patreon says hi
dr. Tyson how far do you think we are
away from determining the theory of
everything ie a theory of quantum
gravity what will we need to perform
experiments that could prove or disprove
a particular hypothesis Chris and
Samantha Cohen from hard Worth New
Jersey so Paul how interconnected is a
theory of everything to what's going on
on the frontier of multiverse thought
well I think it's intimately connected
in the sense that one of the problems we
talked about already was how you would
start the universe off so a presumption
of the this conventional picture is the
universe has a beginning the only only
cosmologists get to sound like God well
this is how we're gonna make the
universe this way the power that they
wield yeah so so the question is how so
that so the idea is that at some point
there was nothing no space no time no
matter no energy that's the presumption
that's the presumption which we can
question but that's the presumption then
suddenly it bursts into something
space-time filled with energy that was
first quantum and then suddenly became
later a few Instructor large enough and
became classical described by general
relativity now
those are words what actually happened
there what's the theory that explain
that creation event or that replaces it
with a better idea let's go to the tape
that reminds me of the you know the Syd
Harris cartoon where the two physicists
at the chalkboard and it's filled with
equations and then at the end of the
bottom right-hand corner it says then a
miracle occurred so the other physicists
um more detail here for what happens at
this stage that's the theory of
everything so that's what we're looking
for it's a so it would dovetail into
what you're trying to describe would
happen after yeah a full theory would
would have to incorporate a quantum
theory of gravity and an explanation of
either this creation from nothing or
something that replaces it with a
different idea
so you hear people talk about the
eternality of matter like that it just
it's not about that it came from
someplace that it just always existed I
mean I've actually heard that as people
that try to explain that's how
everything started and that this just
goes over and over again well so the
idea of this creation idea of this Big
Bang that's traditional Big Bang ideas
if there would have been no matter right
there would have been no space for
matter to even exist in so matter
already presumes a notion that exists in
some space background but we don't know
that this creation idea is right right
so so there are some of us and and their
self included myself included who have
been who have been rethinking the
creation scenario yeah and thinking that
maybe what we thought was a Big Bang was
really a Big Bounce that we universe
went through a period of contraction and
then bounced to expansion so that space
would not have had a created created
moment but would have existed before
during and after that's what I was
trying to say yes there's your analogies
at least in space what do you call this
idea well there there are different
versions of this idea so the Big Bounce
is one is just describing this event
like that two syllables yeah a version
of it the universe undergoes
not just one bounce but periodic bounces
so we call that a cyclic universe so the
universe goes to if you if you are into
your Greek one version of that is called
an erotic universe another version of
worst name ever thank you thank you
by the way once you get done with the
app erotic universe want to make your
way over to the enema universe so ik
products for the Greek woman means what
what are those words from out of the
fire so actually an ancient Greek idea
was the idea of a universe when and went
under regular periods of creation
evolution and then Cataclysm disappear
and then a new universe would be created
an act parodic universe so with phoenix
universe maybe i phoenix is another
version of this otherwise you're just
showing off that you know greek and
imagine if the Big Bang had been called
something else yes something with
multi-syllable eyes at first right then
it's it would not have caught on
that's chin popular culture and parlance
absolutely bang black hole this kind of
thing this is true so marketing is
important market very important we're
gonna take a quick break okay and we
come back to Startalk cosmic queries
edition we've got Paul Steinhardt
physicist at Princeton University and
he's our expert in house on the
multiverse see in a moment
we're back on Startalk cosmic queries
edition today's topic the multiverse
topic I would not dare tackle on my own
so I brought in Chuck nice of course
Chuck knows everything about the
multiverse alright Chuck is reading
questions from you our fan base and I
brought in a ball of Steinhart Princeton
University professor yes physics it's
been a fascinating conversation thus far
and he's been doing some thinking of his
own as a multiverse
so we it's a quick question you're a
crayon ik universe which is repeating
bouncing you remove the need for
singularity is that correct yes
so as time would exist Barbra Cheerilee
far back maybe infinitely far back in
time it's maybe space and time existed
forever
we're just in the latest most recent
cycle I'm gonna ask you a philosophical
question did you come up with this idea
because the singularity was too hard and
so you needed an easier way to
understand the universe or did you have
compelling reasons to go there actually
it's a very practical reason I didn't
have a philosophical outlook at all it
was to get rid of the multiverse problem
because the multiverse caused the
multiverse got two in the back of the
head that's right and then Paul went
leave the gun take the cannoli that was
the motivation though he actually was
the motivation because the multiverse
essentially as I was saying at the
outset destroyed an idea which I thought
explain how the universe could have been
smooth in uniform just because we didn't
properly understand the effect of
quantum physics and that due to these
rare quantum effects that totally
changed the structure that we instead of
getting a smooth universe we expected to
get we got this patch universe which
every outcome is possible so I just want
to you know I want to explain it in a
sentence that feels comfortable with me
and this patchwork universe where you
have causally separated regions that
cannot know about one another they are
nonetheless connected in the fabric of
space-time yes we cannot and should not
think of them as some
separate parallel universe in another
dimension as is so commonly thought of
in movies and the rest yeah okay that's
that is really just a bit mind-blowing
ratably mind-blowing concept all right
this one from Greg Fischer on Facebook
says hi dr. Tyson at all I remember
reading a while back that in a quantum
state electrons were shown to not only
have spin but we're kind of able to jump
or teleport between and within their
shells while this still seems a bit
far-fetched and I'm not a physicist hey
thanks for that Greg thanks for letting
us know
I was for one I was very concerned
what's new and what can be explained
about this so Paul it's not specifically
multiverse but if you're worrying about
quantum phenomenon it's got to show up
at some point we know that when
electrons jump energy levels or even
when particles what we call tunnel from
one state to another state yes the time
delay is basically zero isn't that
correct
and the particle can show up in one
place having traveled from another place
if it tunneled there it got there faster
than the speed of light isn't that
correct
that's the wrong way to think of it I
think it's the wrong way to think about
it I think there's a period of time
during which its location is uncertain
and if you account for that that lost
time that's the time it would take for
that would be longer time that would
take four or equal to the time take
light to travel from its first location
to the other so it's like you would see
it here and then there'd be a period if
you weren't watching that it would
suddenly appear here and then that would
that period of uncertainty would account
for the light travels ok now the period
where you're not watching that's an area
that's a necessary part of this
phenomenon yes right it gets to see it
would mean you'd have to be shining
light on it to see it now you'd be
cheating you'd actually be kicking the
electron and you'd say oh the reason why
it went from here to here is because I
kicked
yeah yeah just the like it's important
that you don't look because then you're
not studying the tunneling phenomena
that's like the old joke I I know how
the teleport and they say prove it and
you say okay I'm gonna go to San
Francisco right now I'm back okay so
just you said something fun and deep as
you have been doing in this time you've
been sharing with us that for a particle
to disappear from one place and reappear
in another spontaneously via some kind
of tunneling phenomenon it does that
because you stopped looking at it the
act of having looked at it you look the
act of looking at it so it keeps it in
that quantum state if you will and this
is some kicks it out or kicks interact
with it now you're setting a different
effect right right and this is happening
all the time for everything it's just
that we can be illuminated by light but
our mass is so high that we don't jump
to another quantum state body and soul
but an electron is such low mass and it
has this interaction capacity with a
photon that you can't shine a photon on
it and expect it to stand there and
smile for you yes okay okay yeah that's
pretty awesome so the act of trying to
measure it changes what you're trying to
measure right you can't measure it
because once you pull out whatever it is
you're measuring that actually affects
it right and the New Age movement
completely misunderstood this thinking
that it's your consciousness that's
somehow affecting it and it's a human
thing no it's the act as the active
measurement is a thing whether or not
the human is doing it you have a machine
right whatever doesn't matter and this
spontaneous process by the way is the
same idea that's involved with petition
the multiverse it's a similar tunneling
or decay like process this case it's a
decay of inflationary energy into matter
and radiation that's occurring randomly
due to quantum effects and in fact it's
random and sometimes proves is a huge
banshan is all part and parcel of this
quantum uncertainty randomness not you
quantum is some badass let me tell you
that's that's crazy it's a powerful
thing yeah and the fact is that I'm
going to be very honest I don't
understand any other I'm just letting
you know nobody but you don't have to by
the way I mean I said was it firemen so
one of the one of the Great's of
yesteryear said the day you say you
understand quantum physics is the
guarantee that you do not because as Lee
said it's not something to understand it
just is oh okay
well then that feel much better we were
freaking out we our our our historical
brethren who discovered this that they
they were freaking out just like you are
right now oh my god a particle a wave
why who what Einstein said God does not
play dice and people will freak out even
Einstein you in good company even today
even today people still there's still a
community of people that debate the
interpretation of quantum mechanics and
then there's another community of us who
just say just get up and computed exact
I mean that common that camper by the
way Jim by the way if I had a time
machine and I somehow found myself in
the 1920s I would be the greatest Herald
er of the discovery of quantum physics
which I think did not get much public
play back in the 1920s when most of the
foundations of it were laid to paper let
me think about newspapers of the day
aren't saying a new branch of physics
has just been discovered it's not there
it's only when it became useful for the
IT revolution and I are tire the
creation storage and retrieval of
information
has anyone been able to fully appreciate
what came out of that error that's
pretty well transistor to you needed you
know partly and parses because it was a
lot of confusion as to how to interpret
the idea and exactly what a pointer was
convey what it meant and what point it
was convincingly true so the point is as
a as a professional physicist you you
study quantum physics which historically
had only been applied to the small now
as a cosmologists when the entire
universe was once small you're invoking
the the rules of quantum physics after
now effect the entire universe Wow and
the effects how that's pretty awesome
the thing about right because when the
large were small quantum physics is
kicking cosmic butt okay and you know
what does particle but and that's in the
Bible the law be small in the small hey
this is Matt even right quest race book
that was a great question that we Matt
Eli from Facebook and also from San
Antonio Texas a little more it wants to
know this a little more existential why
should we take the multiverse Theory
seriously in the first place might there
be extraordinary evidence for this
extraordinary claim who is not the least
bit skeptical I like this question it's
it's you gotta admit Paul to assert
multiple universes is extraordinary and
if you're not on the tail and you're a
theorist
last I checked so you're not even well
of course good theorists think of how to
test and hypotheses have you good
theorists do this do you yeah well I
think I've already sort of played laid
out my cards and said that I think the
multiverse is a sign of breakdown of
this inflationary idea it's a failure
it's a failure mode of the theory
something we didn't expect it wasn't
designed to produce a multiverse it's
something we discovered after the fact
and the problem is that because it
produces an infinite number of patches
of every possible variety if you ask
what the theory predicts the answer is
of nothing or everything or anything
that's so it's a little bit I now again
if it explains everything then in fact
it explains nothing
yes that's what that's so in my view
that makes it no longer a scientifically
interesting theory so it's not testable
even if it's true it's just not
interesting it's not interesting because
anything you'd measure you could say oh
we live in that patch of the universe
and then you measure something else
tomorrow and it doesn't fit that patch
they must be the natural wear both of
those are the fact yeah that's right
yeah and according to the multiverse
idea if it's physically possible and
obviously our physical world is one of
the possibilities then it must exist
somewhere else we're a simulation
you can't get away once you have a bad
idea alright so there you have it okay
hey Matt nice question wait so you agree
that it has it doesn't really set the
standard yet for a testable theory I
think by construction it does not and if
you read what the proponents of the
multiverse say that's exactly what
they'll tell you so what about what
about the quantum foam bursting forth
multiple whole other universes from the
very early universe and these would-be
universes that you would be able to see
in a higher dimension but they don't
interact and they're perfectly separate
fabrics pretty fabric so yeah I don't
know what to make of that that's another
untestable idea in principle so it's
it's another version of a if well so
there are two possibilities one
possibility is that those different
fabric regions have completely different
properties again like the multiverse and
you and it's just random chance
patchwork multiverse to capatch work
multiverse in which wouldn't in which
again you everything could possibly
everything that could happen will happen
in which case it has no scientific
predictive value or it could be that you
have a theory which says actually the
same thing will happen each time every
time you produce one of these fabrics so
that if I suddenly transport it to the
other one imagine doing that it would
look familiar to me mm-hmm that's a
different story that's a predictive
theory but the problem is you can't get
there it's what you're saying yeah and
and so it doesn't have a meaningful
scientific value and isn't it true for
reasons that I never learned because I
never took advanced field theory and
graduate school but my wife did and okay
she is a PhD mathematics I know I know
your wife and she's smarter than you so
but from what I've been told gravity is
not contained in the space-time in which
it is
formed in which you have it so in other
words the the effect of gravity can leak
out of whatever is the membrane that
it's contained and be felt by other
universes outside of that
so unlike electromagnetic radiation
which is trapped within the space time
gravity is not I've heard that so I
think you're referring to theories like
in string theory you have extra
dimensions and where we might live in a
membrane like surface in which we seem
we think we're living in a world of
three space dimensions there's actually
extra dimensions which we our particles
can't access there our light can't move
there so electromagnetic radiation can't
move there but gravity would be felt
even along that extra dimension so that
you we so that for example if there were
another similar membrane parallel to us
now they are thinking about this idea of
parallel and something were happening
over there it let's say a matter lumped
together to form a star right or a black
hole or something like that that would
be felt its gravitational effect why
isn't that dark matter it's a dark
matter our users would be ordinary
matter in a parallel universe is leaking
into ours and we're mysteriously
inventing stuff to account for it when
in fact is just ordinary matter I think
that's that's a conceivable idea that it
could be matter on the other side
another brain and another membrane
that's a small distance away it couldn't
be like our matter because if it were it
would also when it gravitationally
clumped it would produce radiation and
that radiation would affect us as well
in a way that we know we know there
aren't those sources of radiation there
and the dark matter one of the things
about dark matter compared to ordinary
matter is dark or Denari matter
collapses to form stars and stick
together and stick together and sits in
a halo a very diffuse dark matter if
this dark matter were like us but on the
other side it would also collapse and it
wouldn't form the halo which you know of
dark matter that we observe we infer
from measures and there's another little
factor a gravity drops off as one over
distance squared but if you're feeling
gravity from another universe that's
gravity permeating through
other dimension yes and then therefore
gravity from another universe would have
to drop off faster than one over R
squared okay so little but ever so as of
course the foremost authority on this in
the room let me just say what the hell
are you it's time for commercial breaks
you lost me until one over ours gravity
thing there that live if you're spilling
out and you got to go through another
dimension to for it to be felt right
then your equations have to somehow
wreck it recognize that fact I got you
the dilution of gravity as you get so in
other words gravity the surface area of
a sphere as it grows up you're thinning
out whatever the fabric was by the the
square of the distance so I got a fear
that's three times bigger so cuz the
sphere is expanding as nine times the
area and so you see so it's thin it
whatever was there before is now 1/9 is
there so gravity thins out at that rate
okay but now that makes sense of gravity
I'm thinking of this as a blowing up
balloon okay if you want to think way
out into a whole other dimension and
that equation can't just be one over R
squared gotcha now that makes it let me
just go Paul was i okay with that except
for those of you listening at home
you're welcome comes back more on the
anatomy of the multiverse
we're back on Startalk and I'm here with
Chuck nice Sarah and an old friend and
colleague of mine from my Princeton days
Paul Steinhardt
professor of physics and Lord of the
Phoenix universe so Paul is this your
does your chair have an endowed name to
it it does what is that it's called the
Albert Einstein professorship in science
excuse the hell out of it that's pretty
that's pretty rough man okay I'm
thinking with some name there's a rich
guy that just gave money oh no that
Albert Einstein okay so do you realize
you could only be a disappointment
that's the price cause Macquarie's what
else you have multiverse cosmic first we
are talking about this is somewhat in
that range but Michael Ranger from
Twitter says this reality is granular I
love how people put their own little
stuff there things do it let them do
that
how then I can say the Earth's gravity
reach infinitely far wouldn't it
eventually wink out ooh
so let me let me recast that question
yeah it's a good question in a quantum
construct of the universe you cannot get
arbitrarily small things you cannot have
arbitrarily short time intervals
because there's a quantum size that
limits it do we agree ok so if you have
gravity dropping off ever so slowly' 1
over R squared and that means R gets
bigger and bigger gravity gets smaller
and smaller but there's always something
there you can always calculate how much
is there is there some calculation where
the gravity is so low it goes from some
quantum higher-level to apt to zero
did I say that did I make sense in that
question was that a fair interprets a
fair interpretation okay I wasn't sure
if you were talking about time or space
though you're talking about just gravity
yes gravity it's really a from the go
away from Earth so it's gravity right
right right you know it's you know it's
like it's like cleaning up broken glass
there's like a gazillion pieces that
you'll never get it all but eventually
there's the last piece of glass you've
cleaned and there's no more glass left
even though it's felt infinite at the
time so is there a last piece of gravity
that Earth is expressing into the
universe
they're very I'll give you one
interpretation of that question let me
see if that it will will help answer it
so it's important to appreciate that the
earth hasn't always existed it came into
existence so before it came to existence
there was no gravitational field
associated with it okay there was matter
that was going to eventually come
together to form the earth so if you go
far enough out and so that if you go far
enough out in space you would not know
that the earth was about to form ooh we
got to wrap my head around that so earth
is about four and a half billion years
old yes if you go four and a half
billion light years away there's a point
where Earth had not yet assembled yeah
from the void yes if you were looking
for a field of gravity
oh you measure man okay I'm telling you
right now there are people listening to
this and they're just like I am never
doing drugs just take up cosmology
people I'm telling you right now so what
you're saying is you could be there and
you would watch the formation of a
source of gravity in front of you even
though it's too far away to see right
you would feel you'd measure this
gravity arise yes so it'd be like you
know throwing a rock in the in a puddle
and
and eventually the wave is going to meet
you is going to reach out to you and
then you'd be aware that Iraq if you
weren't using your eyes you're just
feeling the water you'd be aware that
something happened except the rock
hitting the puddle was a spontaneous
thing as the Assembly of the earth where
the slow was slower and piecemeal that's
right okay okay so that's that's an
awesome reply but I think it still
avoids the question yes is there a point
where the gravity of something quantum
drops to the strength of gravity
something quantum drops to zero from
some quantum level above it when I say
quantum I don't even mean to I don't
even mean quantum physics so much as can
it's smoothly go to 0 asymptotically or
not that's really the question and you
could say I don't know yeah you're gonna
say they even though you're Princeton
professor you say you know I don't know
well the question could mean I'm more
confused because the question could mean
various things so let me mention another
issue which is there in the the way let
me just say I am glad that right now you
guys are not two surgeons to figure out
how we should approach this open heart
situation is that we think there is a
deep puzzle which is if you if you buy
this idea at the universe began from a
quantum beginning which rather than a
bounce one of the puzzles there is how
do you go from a quantum world to a
world which is described by your 1 over
R squared force and by the laws of
general relativity how do we go from
quantum to classical and at this point
what proponents do is simply wave their
hands and said something must do it and
so we'll just you know sometimes you
work on one side of this something
sometimes on the other but exactly how
that occurred is a mystery and is
another reason to be suspicious of this
set up of a Big Bang leading to a
classical expansion okay all right we'll
give me another question here we go
there we go I'm going to say
I'm sorry I lost his name I've wanted to
answer him yeah Michael here's the deal
we didn't answer your question at all so
so no his race a say we turned it into a
better question that we we turn to
question into a better question uh here
we go here we go
Maria Simon from Facebook would like to
know dr. Tyson what our perception of
time be the same throughout the
multiverse Thanks
I can't wait to see you live on Monday
what are you going on Monday I have no
idea with his child
oh no actually that this shows being
recorded
next week I'm I'm in the Pacific
Northwest I'll catch some public talks
all right there you know maybe one maybe
one of your flock to be Eugene Oregon or
to Seattle but okay so I'm sorry the
question so she's talking about the
perception of time oh yeah yeah is that
going to be consistent so Paul we know
from relativity that the passage of time
is relative to an observer yes so other
than that which we're kind of we live
with and we live with in fact daily you
realize the GPS satellites at their
elevation above Earth experience a
different strength of Earth's gravity
than we do here and I Stein's general
theory of relativity prescribes the
difference in the rate at which it's
clocks tick compared with hours and so
well so what that means is when it is
telling us what time it is we have pre
corrected the change in its time because
of Einstein's general theory LeTip e so
that we all have the same time here on
Earth's surface
gotcha the same time as that no that's
and that makes sense general relativity
at work right at work okay so Paul so we
got this and if you go to another one of
your multiverse pockets could just time
have a whole other kind of thing going
on well certainly there would be no way
to synchronize it compared to our time
so for example
sample one patches would be born at
different times so the period the time
the time they would have transpired
since the creation of our patch to reach
a point where there's earth and people
would be different maybe in this other
patch it might have just been born and
their calendar would be bp4 before patch
yeah so it would be simply no way to to
correlate our time so unlike the case of
the satellite where we can send signals
back and forth to the earth to
synchronize and to make this correction
and only by having that communication
because we can't communicate with one
another there's no meaningful way to
synchronize it in the quantum
fluctuations in the quantum fluctuations
of these patches could time mean
something different there could a
quantum fluctuation change
what time is conceivably it's not part
of the usual multiverse picture okay
it's rather conventional in that sense
that the patches would more or less have
normal space and time like we think
about here although some of them could
be in some cases the space could be
space time could be so warped that time
could never lose its quantum its
quantumness it might remain quantum and
have a sort of no classical meaning in
some patches that's conceivable and
that's a kind of version of what you're
what you're asking like that so time
would just not be even fit not even a
thing it may not they may not even be
yeah right they could figure out some
other way to meet you they put it in a
bottle I couldn't meet you at the corner
because space wouldn't have a meaning
either oh the corner would the corner
wouldn't be there yeah we got time just
for a quick lightning round okay
soundbite answers naggy Jonathon Agee
went from Twitter wants to know this
well quantum gravity means ER is
incorrect since qf t is based on flat
space-time and gr is a curvature he's
just showing off yes yes
that's question Gabriel from Twitter
wants to know this what if anything is
stopping gravity waves from traveling
faster than the speed of light yeah hmm
well relativity you are really good at
this part okay we gotta take it as an
answer because this is the lightning
round look it up in other words
relativity does not allow anything to go
faster than light therefore gravity
waves are not traveling faster than
light correct even though they be
gravity and not light that's right okay
all right
Don's Dayton's own quick Twitter says
this chemists telescope be made to see
so far that it sees the Big Bang what is
the limit of telescopes including the
ones that we launched into space because
light takes time to move in one location
to another it means as you look out in
space you see things not as they are but
as they they were and as you just take
that far enough back yes in principle
you can see the birth of the universe
provided that there is matter out there
that is as old as the universe ok so now
the reason why we have any evidence of
the Big Bang at all is because we have
this expanding horizon that is washing
over parts of the whole universe that
was born 13.8 billion years ago here's
what would scare the daylights out of me
if all of a sudden the Cosmic Microwave
Background began to disappear Oh would
mean that our cosmic horizon would be
entering a region of our universe where
there is no longer any matter we'd
reached the physical edge of our
universe and then that wave would is
coming our way no then then there would
be no cosmology because we would have no
information about what happened in the
past that's why we can see the Big Bang
at all okay yeah you okay with that Paul
well Microwave Background is
disappearing right if it's it's being
redshifted away due to the expansion of
the universe so in fact it is fading
from view but that's not because we've
reached the edge it's because over time
that's going to happen just because the
universe is continuing - yes yes so
because of the expanding universe the we
are diluting the evidence of the Big
Bang yes that is coming to us from that
from from the part of the universe that
we are seeing being born right now yes
however if that is not fading simply at
the rate of the universe expansion but
if it's fading at some faster rate than
that that could be evidence that we are
running out of matter in the universe
for our horizon to engulf all right we
are way over time here you've been
you've been listening and possibly
watching Startalk the the cosmic queries
addition on the multiverse let me thank
my friend and colleague Paul Steinhardt
Princeton University Chuck nice yes I
think of Chuck Norris said calm and calm
and confused alright you've been
listening to Startalk possibly even
watching it I've been your personal
guide through this universe my name is
Neil Tyson and as always I bid you to
keep looking up
this is Startalk
you